[Music]  since the civil rights movement the  sit-in protest has been a powerful tool  for affecting social change but it's  hard to be effective when you have to  keep getting up to go to the bathroom  now there's no rest for your protests  with civil disobedience absorbent  wetness protection disguised as an  attractive dress pant our patented  fabric soaks up liquids and blocks  odours keeping you dry when it matters  most available in three comfort levels  light change medium progress and full  Gandhi so your quest for justice can  keep going and going and going  civil disobedience for the sit-in you  can [ __ ] in  [Applause]  you  [Applause]  you